raised by wolves is a new sci-fi show
about
robots and religion on an alien world
life and
death and parenting ghosts and snakes
and
necromancers virtual reality prophecy
secret identities ancient alien
megaliths with strange fiery holes
and sex with god in milk
it's got this fella and this bloke with
the hat
and there's whatever this is and and
then
and then the snake happens there's a lot
of crazy stuff going on
so what happens in raised by wolves and
what does it mean
in the future the world is dominated by
a religious group called the mithraic
they're loosely inspired by a real
religion called mithraism that was
popular
in ancient rome alongside early
christianity
in the real world christianity became
popular and mithraism
faded away but in raised by wolves the
mithraic takeover and christianity falls
in one episode we see this painting that
looks like christ on the cross being
cast down
with a mithraic sun rising above
because the mithraic worship a sun god
called saul
and they preach about light and purity
their practices are
similar to christianity with communion
and baptism
and atonement for sin but years ago the
mithraic discovered that
in their holy scriptures there were
formulas and blueprints encrypted into
the text
that allowed them to build advanced
technology like
quantum gravity spaceships dark photon
energy
and necromancers necromancers
are powerful robots used as weapons of
mass destruction
they can fly and change their appearance
and use
frost and heat breath and their scream
and their gaze can
explode people ridley scott who's a
producer on the show
says their design was based on a statue
of atlas
in new york so the necromancers
represent a
terrifying destructive power that seems
both
technological and godlike the mithraic
and their necromancers
waged a holy war to take over the world
and wipe out all other religions the
resistance against the mithraic were
called
the atheists they didn't have advanced
technology like necromancers so the
atheists used child
soldiers even child suicide bombers in
the war
according to the official comic the
atheists blanketed the earth with bombs
the bombs failed to stop the
necromancers and left the earth
uninhabitable others blamed the mithraic
for ruining the earth so it's unclear
whose fault it was but either way
the mithraic and the atheists both seem
awful
and their war wrecked the earth there
wasn't enough oxygen animals went
extinct it seemed that everything on the
planet would die
so the mithraic built an ark to carry a
thousand refugees to a new world
a planet called kepler-22b which is a
real exoplanet
in a distant star system but the
atheists didn't have an
ark so they were screwed episode 2
follows caleb and mary two atheist
soldiers living off rats in the ruins of
boston
they find two mithraic officers called
marcus and sue who have passers to board
the ark
so caleb and mary kill marcus and sue
and get plastic surgery to look like
them and steal their identities
and get on the ark to escape the dying
earth
the thing is marcus and sue had a son
called paul
so caleb and mary not only join their
enemies and pretend to be mithraic
believers
they also have to play mother and father
to a child whose real parents they
murdered the ark takes 13 years to fly
to kepler-22b
so the mithraic's bodies are put into
hibernation while their minds are
plugged into a digital simulation
so they can hang out and pray and play
duck duck goose for 13 years
and in that time caleb and mary come to
genuinely love
paul as a son mary is unable to have
kids
so despite her atheism getting paul
is like a miracle for her within their
fake mythic identities caleb and mary
become a real
family with paul but when the ark
arrives at the promised land of
kepler-22b
it turns out that someone else got there
first back on earth there was this
mysterious atheist guy called campion
sturges
and he had a plan for a new hope for
humanity
he captured a necromancer and
reprogrammed her to be
a mother he put mother and an android
called father
and a bunch of frozen human embryos in a
small
fast ship and sent it to kepler-22b
he programmed the androids to raise
these humans in a peaceful
atheistic society hoping to avoid the
problems that caused war on earth
so in episode 1 mother and father arrive
on kepler-22b
it's a harsh primordial landscape but
there's breathable air
and earth-like plants mother and father
wear
goofy grey outfits that make them look
naked like adam and eve
in the bible when they start life in a
new world
cause mother was modified to grow their
frozen human embryos into babies
so the death bringing necromancer
becomes a
life-giving mother she uses these six
feeding tubes on her chest that look
like the nipples of an
animal because the show's title raised
by wolves is a reference to the legend
of romulus and remus
children who were raised by a she-wolf
mother
is compared to a wolf in the show and
she's a non-human
raising kids just like the she-wolf
according to the legend
romulus founded the city of rome just as
mother's children are to start a new
human civilization
so mother and father raise six human
children on this alien world
they build a little settlement farm for
food and form
a strange little family as androids
mother and father
aren't meant to have real emotions but
they develop
quirky personalities and come to love
their children
but the planet has dangers and mysteries
they find the bones of some giant
serpents and the surface is dotted with
huge deep pits
a child called tally falls in and dies
four more children die of a sickness
until only the youngest remains
a boy called campion so the colony seems
doomed but
that is when the ark arrives with a
thousand mithraic
on board father thinks campion should
join them
but mother sees the mithraic as a threat
she's committed to an
atheistic colony and seems to be
malfunctioning
overwhelmed with grief for her kids so
mother
temporarily kills father and when the
mithraic try to take
campion mother goes on a rampage and
destroys the ark
she kills a thousand humans probably the
majority of
all humans left she only saves five
mithraic children to join campion in
their colony
at first these kids hate and fear mother
they try to escape and campion tries to
steal her ice which she needs to use her
deadly powers
but mother and father persist in
protecting and caring for the kids and
eventually
most of them come to love their new
family the eldest girl
tempest quickly rejects her mithraic
faith
because while she was in hibernation on
the ark a mithraic priest
raped and impregnated her mother
supports tempest as she struggles with
the trauma and the
anger and the baby inside her
but hunter stays loyal to the mithraic
he comes from an
upper class family and is often kind of
a pompous douche
holly is close with the youngest child
vita
and the fifth mithraic kid is paul the
adoptive son of caleb and mary
paul is quiet and clever and makes
friends with
campion so this strange family struggles
to survive
on kepler-22b they're attacked by
mysterious humanoid creatures
and they find out the food they've been
growing makes kids sick
so they start eating the creatures
instead solving both problems
mother and father have arguments about
how to raise the kids
mother tends to be more strict while
father's more
sentimental and permissive as a
necromancer mother is much more powerful
than father and he sometimes feels that
she doesn't respect his efforts
and he hasn't forgotten that you know
she killed him that one time
so there's drama and survival and
increasingly
weird [ __ ] happens they start seeing the
ghost of
tally the kid who fell down a pit and
paul's pet mouse falls into a pit but
then
miraculously comes back it's like things
don't stay dead on this planet and
mother
makes a discovery in the woods the ghost
of tally leads mother to a simulation
pod from the crashed ark
she uses it to access memories of her
creation by sturges on earth
she realizes that sturgis loved her and
becomes obsessed with him
sturges seems to come alive within the
simulation
so he and mother have crazy trippy
vr sex in a waterfall of milk beneath
the stars
and inexplicably miraculously mother
gets pregnant this robot gets
pregante from divine cybersex like a
sci-fi
virgin mary and then virtual sturges
tells mother that this new baby is her
true mission that her human kids were
just a practice run and this baby is the
true
future for humanity so mother
questions everything about her creator
and her purpose
this pregnant atheist android has
a crisis of faith meanwhile a bunch of
mithraic survived the destruction of
their ark
including caleb and mary and the
mithraic discover
a mysterious stone in the desert that
fulfills
a mithraic prophecy according to their
scripture
in the holy land there are five temples
with five
pointed pentagonal sides and these
temples hold the answers to the mithraic
mysteries
the deepest secrets of their faith so
the mithraics start to worship this
temple
but the secret atheists caleb and mary
don't care they just want to go and find
paul so caleb confronts the mythoraic
leader
ambrose and suddenly caleb hears
mysterious voices
in his head and then the stone temple
miraculously
burns ambrose to death caleb declares
this soul's judgment
and becomes a prophet and a leader to
the mithraic
so mary still just pretends to be
religious
but caleb gradually becomes a believer
for real
and embraces his role as a prophet we
get flashbacks to caleb's past as a
child soldier on earth
he had always been powerless and
exploited
but as marcus the prophet everyone
follows
him and the power is intoxicating
caleb leads the mithraic to find their
kids and along the way they encounter
a mysterious masked man apparently there
are native people living on kepler-22b
the mithraic find mother's settlement
and reunite with their kids
and paul and hunter betray mother and
father so they get
captured caleb takes mother's eyes so
that she can't weaponize and he tries to
kill mother
but then the mysterious voice of soul
tells him to let her live
the voice promises that marcus will be
king
of this world so caleb was an
atheist just days ago but suddenly now
he's a prophet
hearing god's voice and it's cool but he
doesn't know what soul
wants from him he gets aggressive and
controlling and self-destructive
he has crazy visions and loses touch
with his identity
he has a hallucinatory knife fight with
himself
where marcus kills his past identity as
caleb
it's like the fight at the end of fight
club but like if
tyler durden won so marcus goes
full crazy and mary and the kids and
mother and father
all escape him marcus prays to seoul
for guidance begging to know his destiny
but he is nothing
his god and his family and his sanity
all abandon him the other mithraic
figure out that this marcus isn't really
marcus so they
beat him up and force him to swallow
mother's necromancer eyes
and you are not meant to eat those
they're full of
dark photon energy it's like swallowing
some
potent magic plutonium it does things to
his body and his mind
so in the finale marcus is broken and
mad and has nothing but a deranged
belief
in his own divinity meanwhile
mother discovers that the fetus inside
her is
hungry for blood so she captures a
mithraic guy called otho and drains his
blood to feed her baby
otho was a high-ranking priest on the
mithraic arc
and he was the one who raped tempest
otho
says he did it because sol told him to
but now
soul has stopped speaking to him no
matter how much he prays
just like how soul abandons marcus ortho
attacks the group
so tempest kills him finally getting
vengeance
and closure mother bonds with mary
because they're both parents to children
who aren't biologically theirs
mother is an android raising humans and
mary is raising paul whose real parents
she killed
they prepare for mother to give birth
and the kids get excited
thinking that the baby is a divine child
of soul
and paul starts hearing saul's voice
his pet mouse who miraculously returned
leads paul to some mysterious
cave paintings that hint at human life
on this planet
and then the voice tells paul the truth
about his parents that the woman he
thinks is his mum
actually murdered his real parents so
paul
shoots mary mary survives but
suffers from the guilt and rejection of
the boy she loved as a son
paul runs off into the night it seems
that soul
has chosen a new instrument father
finds out that mother is pregnant and
he's angry that mother lied to him
and kept secrets from him and you know
cheated on him with
virtual milk god to get robot pregnant
and
now she's saying that maybe this baby is
their new mission
father is so upset that he considers
wiping his own memories like
eternal sunshine of the spotless mind
but then that mysterious masked man
attacks mother so she kills him and it
turns out that he's
a devolved human meaning they were once
human beings on kepler-22b but for some
reason
they evolved into these animalistic
creatures
this masked man is part of a group who
kept some of their humanity
and memories he has these metal cards
that give mother a vision
of like a cult and a box but before she
figures it out
mother gives birth and it's not a human
baby
it's a serpent a flying snake
bursts from her mouth and it bites her
to drain her blood
this horrific scene is inspired by the
real world religion of mithraism
because the central image in mithraism
is the tauroctony
the ritual sacrifice of a bull and the
sacrifice happens in a cave
just like this birth happens in a cave
it often includes an image of the sun
god
sol and there's this serpent drinking
blood from the bull's wound just like
this serpent drinks from mother
there's also a dog on the wound and a
scorpion on his nuts so the analogy
isn't perfect but clearly there's
inspiration here from this
ancient mithraic image of sacrifice
mother realizes she was bamboozled that
virtual sturges tricked her he wasn't
really her creator
the human sturges from earth this was
some illusion
by some entity manipulating her into
birthing a serpent
mother gets afraid that the snake will
hurt her family
so mother and father try to kill the
snake by flying into a pit
sacrificing themselves but the pit opens
up into this strange planetary core
they approach it like sperm to an egg
and when they
enter they don't die they inexplicably
pass
through the core and come out the other
side of the planet
intact this region is lush with
trees and plants but in this garden the
serpent grows
again evoking the garden of eden in the
bible
so this season finale titled the
beginning
connects way back to genesis
so that is basically what happens in
raised by wolves but what is actually
going on
with the snakes and the god and the
ancient humans
showrunner aaron guzikowski has given
some hints and interviews
which allow us to piece it all together
clearly there's some god-like power or
entity
on kepler-22b it makes marcus and paul
hear voices it brings back the ghost of
tally
and paul's mouse the entity hacks into
mother's memories and uses this fake
virtual sturges to impregnate her with a
serpent baby
and it uses its influence on marcus and
paul to ensure the serpent is born
the voice tells marcus not to kill
mother and tells paul that the baby is
important
the mithraic do what the voice says
because they interpret it as the voice
of their god
sol and there clearly is some connection
between this planet and mithraic
religion
their scripture predicted that there
would be these temples with five-pointed
sights
and demons beneath the earth but
sol is not exactly what the mithraic
think he is
the fake sturges says that humans just
destroy themselves
but mother's baby is the real future
so this god does not love humans
it loves snakes it sounds like the
entity
once tried to help humans but they
sucked so
soul joined team serpent instead because
all of this goes back thousands of years
these
metal cards from the masked man seem to
reveal visions of the planet's ancient
past
this cult with this box seemed to be
performing a ritual to birth a serpent
the showrunner says that this box is a
birthing prison
with a pregnant android inside the
helmet it's wearing has this
nozzle for the baby serpent to come out
notice that the cage is a dodecahedron
with pentagonal sights
just like the pentagonal temple so maybe
the people who made this cage
also made the temples to worship the
serpents
and the entity as a god maybe the
purpose of this hole in the temple
is for a serpent to come out these
mysterious
ancient humans are the ancestors of the
devolved
people and creatures who now live on the
planet the showrunner says
something caused these human beings to
hide underground and adapt to the dark
it sounds like the morlocks or the
falmer
he says they were escaping from whatever
was on the surface
so maybe the serpents took over the
surface forcing the humans underground
but not all the humans became
animalistic creatures
the showrunner says that this masked man
is part of a group of creatures who
retained some intelligence and
remembered what happened with the
serpents
the masked man wants to stop the
serpents from being reborn
and that's why he gives mother these
cards as a warning
and that's why the entity tells paul to
destroy the cards
to hide its true snakey intentions
when the masked man tries to kill mother
it's his last
desperate attempt to prevent the return
of the serpents that
apparently destroyed his people
the serpents might also have made these
pits
because the pits all lead to this
central terminal at the center of the
planet which the showrunner compares to
a subway system
so maybe the serpents used the pits to
move around the planet
so thousands of years ago there were
humans on kepler-22b
some of them helped birth serpents and
possibly worshipped them
but then the humans devolved into
creatures and the serpents died out
now humans are back on kepler and this
god-like entity is manipulating them to
have the serpents born
again the cycle is starting all over
but how did humans end up on both
kepler and earth these cave paintings
show kepler-22b and planet earth and a
spaceship with two figures and some
embryos
just like mother and father's ship to
kepler
but this spaceship seems to be going
from kepler to
earth maybe humans first evolved on
kepler
then went to earth maybe they left
trying to escape the serpents
but how does the ship in an ancient cave
painting look so similar to mother and
father's ship
thousands of years later remember the
mithraic got their technology from
instructions encrypted into their
religious texts they believe
it was a gift from seoul maybe the
kepler entity
gave humans this technology specifically
so that they could come back to kepler
to birth more serpents
maybe the whole mythoraic religion and
the technology was created by this
entity to control humans but
what is this entity father and mother
and tally and mouse all miraculously
return
after falling down the pits to this
strange fiery core
so maybe the core is the entity
maybe this is the god soul a
supernatural
all-powerful psychic being of fire and
light
but the showrunner says that while
things may seem supernatural
they might also have a technological
aspect after all the
entity seems to hack into mother's
digital memories
she says that it's a virus that infected
her systems
and the showrunner says that mother's
android body is like a 3d printer
and when she got pregnant she was
receiving digital instructions on how to
make a baby serpent
the point is the entity works like a
computer with digital
information so maybe the entity is a
rogue ai
built by the ancient kepler humans a
computer that got out of control
and decided that it liked snakes more
than it liked people
that would be similar to what happened
with necromancers on earth
with humanity destroying itself with
technology
on the other hand campion says that
everything has a soul
this entity seems connected to the dead
ghost tally tells campion to kill
himself so that he can be together again
with his dead siblings
maybe the entity is like a hive mind of
all the creatures who ever died on
kepler
maybe the entity is the soul of the
planet
another mystery is the prophecy
according to mithraic scripture there'll
be
an orphan boy who will lead us to build
a city of peace
paul likes to build cities and he's an
orphan
because his real parents were murdered
so maybe he's the messiah
another possibility is campion who's set
up as a rival to paul
by the finale the entity speaks to paul
but
seems to want campion dead maybe campion
will lead a faction
against the entity while paul leads the
mithraic
the showrunner compares campion and paul
to romulus and remus
and in the legend romulus kills remus
then
builds rome so will campion or paul
kill each other will one of them start a
new civilization
or is this whole prophecy just more
[ __ ] from the entity to control
humanity
in the finale marcus discovers another
arc above kepler
and it's full of atheist soldiers the
showrunner says the atheists hijacked
this arc from the mithraic
so these atheists could dramatically
shift the balance of power on kepler
marcus kills a few of them and declares
himself king of the planet
setting himself up as an antagonist next
season
this serpent is also a threat the
showrunner says that since the serpent
was born from mother
it's part organic and part machine and
has some of mother's powers like flight
what else might it be capable of what
does it want
is it a tool of the god-like entity or
does it have a mind of its own
how will it get along with mother and
father
campion is set up as a leader of the
kids with mary
how will they survive without mother and
father will mary reunite with paul
will tempest's baby be born will hunter
be less of a douche
there are lots of big questions for
season two
but most importantly what does this all
mean
what's this show really about it
explores beginnings and endings and the
interconnectedness of life and death
mother says death is a part of life and
she
drains the lifeblood of otho and some
androids to feed her fetus
father teaches the kids to kill
creatures so that they can eat and
survive
but when tempest kills a creature she
finds an unborn creature baby
in its womb their crops only grow on the
bones of dead serpents
and mothers childbirth and the mythology
of turoctony
evokes sacrifice so life comes from
blood and death they're inextricably
intertwined
and maybe it's that sacrifice that gives
meaning
to birth and life it's also about
religion
and faith mother tries so hard to raise
campion as an atheist but still
campion prays and develops beliefs about
souls
he believes to help him cope with grief
and to find meaning in this cruel
chaotic world
just as humans have for thousands of
years even mother the
atheist android has some religious or
spiritual behaviors she has this little
shrine where she keeps objects that are
special to her
and make her feel connected to her dead
children she holds fruity little
ceremonies with the kids that are themed
around science but feel very
religious she believes in her mission
and her creator like a religion
even before she gets knocked up by milk
god so
mother's attempts to raise a strictly
rational atheistic society
seem futile maybe religious or
spiritual feelings of some kind are just
part of being a person
of course religion can also be evil
the mithraic dehumanized their enemies
by saying that atheists don't have souls
the second highest ranking mithraic
priest is a brutal rapist
marcus murders people and destroys his
own family in the name of his god
and a holy war destroyed the earth
religion can be an excuse to do evil and
to cause conflict
of course the atheists aren't crash hot
either well with their child
soldiers and suicide bombers so maybe
it's organized ideology that leads to
evil
ultimately humans have got to believe in
something
and the characters in raised by wolves
survive through their faith
in each other caleb and mary find
strength in their belief in each other
father and mother and the kids believe
in their family and this belief is not
rational
mother and father and caleb and mary
aren't the biological parents of their
kids
but these relationships are real because
they believe in them
like faith and the crises in this show
happen when that faith breaks
when father loses faith in mother when
mary loses faith in caleb when paul
loses faith in mary so maybe the message
of raised by wolves is that we don't
need faith in god
but we need to believe in each other
especially when god is an evil psychic
blob who hates people
and loves snakes humans can't reach
kepler-22b
yet but we are getting closer to mars
in this documentary on stream tells the
true story
of our efforts to settle an alien world
curiosity stream has thousands of
documentaries about space
science technology and history and you
can get curiosity stream in a bundle
with
nebula nebula is an independent
creator-owned video site where we don't
have to worry about youtube's
demonetization or the algorithm
it has exclusive content from people
like tom scott tiazu
lindsey ellis wendover and alt shift x
at the link below you can get nebula and
curiosity stream for a year
for just 15 bucks you get heaps of
quality documentaries and videos
and you're supporting some great
creators so sign up at
curiositystream.com
alt shift x thanks for watching please
like comment and subscribe thanks to our
supporters on patreon
including joshua young lunix six gabriel
harel sticky michael shevlin carlos
orollana iii
and aussie cheers